رحله طويله ومرعبه الى بر الامان اثقلت
كاهل هؤلاء الطلاب الافارقه وزادت
معاناتهم اخر ليله هانئه في المكان الذي
احتضنت طموحاتهم انزلت الرعب في نفوسهم
وتركت مئات النيجيريين في العراء لمده
سبعه ايام مؤلمه
حقائب مكدسه لملم هؤلاء فيها ما طالت
ايديهم اولا فلم تعد الذكريات تهم انما
الخلاص اهم
دول غنيه مثل الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
ارسل الطائرات لاجلاء رعاياها بينما كافح
العديد من الافارقه لايجاد مخرج من
العاصمه التي مزقتها الحرب
تكدس الالاف في الحافلات والشاحنات في
الرحله الممتده لثمائه كيلو متر برا من
الخرطوم الى بورسودان في ولايه البحر
الاحمر للصعود على متن السفينه بينما توجه
اخرون صوب الشمال لمسافه تبلغ الف كيلو
متر الى حدود مصر ليجدوا انفسهم عالقين في
صفوف انتظار تستمر اياما للسماح لهم
بالعبور
لكن مع تزايد الاعداد وشح الوقود قفزت
اسعار التنقل الى مئات الدولارات لتكون
بعيدا عن متناول الكثيرين ومن بينهم
الطلبه
يا من هنا وكان المكان غير صحيا ابدا لقد
كان موقفا صعبا للغايه
الحكومه النيجيريه حاولت استئجار 250
حافله لاجلاء حوالي
5500 من مواطنيها لكنها لم تستطع توفير
الا اربعين حافله
رحله على الجمر عاشها هؤلاء بالشقاء
والعناء لا يبرد وهاجها سوى حضن الوطن ولو
لم يكن حاله افضل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات